yeah let's get into this [ __ ] show
dog this piece of [ __ ]
uh so off the heels of the success of
our new segment last week cats
dms we wanted to do it again but i just
assumed it'd be all guys just trying to
get on the show dm and cat i'm sure you
got some weird ones this week dude i
guess
chappelle too oh you got something yeah
yeah i sent you one
yeah i want that dark dolphin yeah
people say yeah i want to train that
dark dolphin
i want that chocolate dolphin bro dude i
got people coming
in the streets i'm let me slip your ass
and then laugh and i'm like
bro save that [ __ ] for a cat you guys
are disgusting man
you guys are disgusting so we uh brought
in a special guest to do it
i bet her dms are filled look bro all
right oh yeah
yeah you look great your face good
afternoon young lady
and can you turn the camera again yeah
what's up girl
can we turn it up a little um
what's going on hannah we have actually
been fixing my grandparents roof
today oh that's sweet of you yeah that's
nice of you
it's leaking i mean i don't know
anything about that stuff but my dad
does
oh nice um raptor
we are just still sitting here
we're in the same place you left us in
we've just been waiting for you to call
he's been patiently waiting yeah he's
been he's a little nervous
we're good to see we're happy we're
we're good to see you today
how are you holding up with uh is it
crazy where you're at are there protests
and stuff or no
it's not too crazy here but i live in
the middle of nowhere
so yeah that helps yeah yeah
i've heard about it and i've seen it all
we went to the beach this past weekend
and they wouldn't let us in some places
because they were
worried that protesters were about to be
there oh yeah they got abused
what beach did y'all go to panama
we buried a friend of mine down there
and i swear to god i don't know if we
ever dug him up
so if you find them keep keep them
posted did you go to spring break there
ever
yeah i did we only live a few hours from
there so
yeah let's go down there and make day
trips and stuff yeah i like the beach
david i like going to destin too destin
is beautiful oh yeah we both fish down
there
oh yeah well we had a question for you
nick what are we asking yeah uh we're
gonna read some of her dms uh because
she's on her phone cat's gonna read it
for her
oh yes hey i bet you get some weird dms
and not just from catfish you feel me
i get some really weird dms did you uh
hear from any people that watch this
show or no
i did i heard from a bunch and were they
decent people
they seemed like it nice i was actually
surprised at how many of the people that
i
went to school with and knew personally
listen to y'all's podcast
i'll love it little rural alabama
yeah my well we had a lot of people
asking us about you too i think uh
everybody i ran into was curious about
the fishing curious about that fishing
girl
you know just wanted to really you're a
big fan
they loved you oh i'm sure
yes ma'am all right
well speaking of noodling let's hear
this uh some of the messages that came
in cat has them right here
so this one says how much do i have to
pay for nudes
because i will literally send any amount
wow i bet and have you ever considered
uh and i mean you know i'm not judging
you
i'm not judging you i've always really
wanted to like i got a few that are like
really big male friends one of them has
a mullet
yeah i've really considered like sending
them pictures of him
that's hilarious make sure you get the
money first though you know
oh yeah up front money up front make
sure it's cash
yeah money up front and penis up front
if you send a nude apparently
this dude said he will literally send
any amount of money though so
pick a number yeah would you ever
consider that on any other level i mean
i think everybody you know even if you
made it look like art or something like
if you're
you know what i'm talking about trying
to get a tan maybe and then just like
you know
doing your thing and then hold the fish
up to block most of the parts yeah what
if you held a fish that blocked like
ollie or like uh
you'd be surprised i said fish bros
there's like a fish
women do that and it's called fish fries
and they like hold the fish over there
oh wow you've just given us a gift young
lady
that is fantastic we're gonna have to
check that out let's hear a couple more
that came in
so this one starts off saying nice belly
are you that strong
smiling emoji okay wanna have sex
whoa okay you know he's direct though
yep hey you can't blame me for trying he
just threw it all out there
and have you ever met a man through your
uh dms on ig
that you went on a date with or anything
not since
my instagram blew up i mean before
anybody knew who i was and i just had
like a thousand followers yeah
yeah smart yeah that's pretty normal
yeah because now it can be a lot of uh
it can be a lot of transients really
passing through there a lot of catfish
no pun intended
yeah ain't no doubt a lot of weirdos too
yeah a lot of real bull heads if you
know what i'm saying
let's read another one of these that
came in this one is an international one
it says
hey when you coming when you coming
fishing in the uk
we have some good pike and tout i think
he means trout
would love to show you around i want to
suckle on your fishy bits
whoa that makes me feel hannah that
makes you feel sick
fishy [ __ ] god suckle god damn bro
it's at least nice that it came from
abroad though it's at least nice
you know what i'm saying there is i read
it in the accent in my head
there you go you're worldwide hannah
worldwide
and have you ever considered have you
ever thought of doing like a uh
noodling expo uh you know traveling and
doing that in some sort of way or no
lord i don't even know i mean we've
taken so many different people
and done it in so many different states
it's hard because catfishing is just
like any other thing you'll never know
how good it's going to go or how bad
last weekend we had a canadian now
oh god hunt with him
this fall so he came down and caught
catfish with us
and clash of accents the whole time oh
yeah what did he think about it what did
he think about
53 pound fish really damn
and how do they how do you set this up
with them obviously not through dms i'm
sure you have a legit
site because you can't just be dm and
these dudes but yeah come on down and
give an address and stuff
and stuff go into all this got it that
was basically through
like instagram and email and all this
other stuff but
and uh how much do you like how much is
it to go on a tour because i feel like
you could probably charge with more of
an exclusive rate you know than somebody
like
um one of us yeah or that shirtless guy
we saw a couple episodes yeah that
shirtless guy that older man oh
man that was probably my dad
does he have a beard yeah no
maybe it was it could have been is your
dad out of shape
no no my dad's like ripped oh this
ain't him your dad could probably charge
a lot more money then yeah this dude was
uh fully together not ripped at all
um how much do you how much is a
noodling experience how much is that
experience because i feel like you could
charge a premium
we probably could but we've never done
any of that i'm not really sure what
kind of license you have to have i think
it's better to have like a charter
license because you'd be taking people
in your boat
we just hadn't been through all the
legalities of it yeah
wow i bet people would pay a pretty
penny for that experience especially
some of these guys because this next
text right here said what did it say it
says
i'll pay you forty dollars for a pick of
your poop oh my god
oh no and that's bait in some countries
that's why theo didn't catch any fish oh
tell her how you didn't catch any fish
oh yeah if you could do some tips he
went he went fishing
he caught nothing i didn't even get a
dang bite i mean heck
i didn't even i used cat food for a
little while and we used
worms and cat food seafood
so y'all just need to come noodling with
us see and what do you hide a little
bait in your arm or something do you put
a little oh no
oh no you just stick your hand in the
hole and then take it oh my god
that's like that's like just believing
in the lord you just gotta go in there
and free oh yeah
all right let's read this let's read
this next one
this one this one says i see you're
pretty good at hand
i see you're pretty good at noodling but
can you handle a noodle
legit question how many do you get that
use noodle in that respect it's like an
easy leaf i feel like
a lot it's hacked
do you open them all up these days do
you respond to them or every
you respond to some every once in a
while i respond to decent ones but any
of them like this i just screenshot
and add them to my album with all the
other
problems wow
[Music]
yeah noodling through these perverts
it's so entertaining i bet it is let's
hear let's hear another one
next one ain't entertaining this one
says
putting your hands on those fish you'll
like putting them on something else
smirky emoji just kidding i was talking
about
fishing the whole time please don't
block me i jerk off to you with my
two-inch pepper
that if you want could be inside of you
sorry
that was my friend that wasn't your
friend
this is sad i'm sorry this happens to
you oh my god
this is kind of vulgar too that one that
one was a little i just like the sorry
it was my friend but
yeah i didn't read through all of it it
was a bad liar yeah i'm sorry yeah
i'm sorry this is happening to you and
i'm sorry i think most
i think most uh attractive girls deal
with this though
yeah yeah it's probably it's good to
bring awareness to it
it's probably we're doing the lord's
work really i don't know what we're
doing
what's that hannah i said i just want to
know if it ever works
yeah yeah they're shooting their shot
they're putting their hands in them dark
murky waters helping you bite
yeah yeah um
and here's one more this one is kind of
cute actually
this one says if your standards are as
low as your squats holla at your boy
that was actually that one's fun that's
pretty cute
you know amy schumer she met not her
husband but the guy she dated for years
she met him on uh
instagram on dms he's a chef right uh
and this is before that guy this guy
this man made tables table man but um
beautiful man too i met him i think his
name was chris uh no that that's her
current husband but
anyway but yeah people meet people you
know a lot well
i think i think it's like eighty percent
of people meet online whether it's dms
or a dating app
is there a fishing dating app like
groupers r us or something
yeah no idea
we could we if you're looking for
business ideas
dude you could if you want yeah if you
wanted to start a fishing dating app i
think that would be uh
go fish yeah that'd be a kid yeah
brandon
they already have a fishing dating app
what do you uh is there a product or
something that you do sell is there
something that you sell so is there some
hannah merch that we could get
i'm actually working on that right now
to be honest with you my best friend
through
college and i'm a bridesmaid her wedding
i think on the last podcast oh yeah we
talked about that
oh that's right she got her dress fitted
but she's a graphic designer so i'm
getting her to come up with
two designs for us to put on some shirts
and stuff
well we'll rock it here yeah if you send
us some we'll rock them whenever you get
them we need an l and a double xl
that would be awesome but you can only
rock them if you'll come catfishing with
it
oh no we're down oh i'm so down yeah i
think i think cove is over
yeah covin's over see as long as he goes
first i'll stand behind brennan and hold
on to his back
yeah i promise i'm down to do it yeah if
you don't mind uh
two men and one riding piggy back with
the fish
i don't that scares the fish away but
we'll try it i'll be the net i'll be the
guy with that
net boy
okay brendan faints too i'll go in there
you know on that backup
yeah um well yeah hannah you got to let
us know when you got some merch we'd
love to support it and we're sorry that
we we're sending a lot of these perverts
your way
i think the creeps were there before
though it just seemed a little worse
yeah the crates were there before i
hadn't really got any creeks from me
do you ever get any haters who would
hate on you do you ever get oh my
goodness
really so many invaders oh yeah
especially since the
hunt and all too really and they're like
oh the only reason
the only reason you catch those fish is
because you got a nice body or you know
the excuses
yeah i get death threats and all kinds
of stuff
threats death threats i'll send you some
of those dms
damn why they have that that's the one i
want to see damn the hate is
real oh [ __ ] you gonna kill these fish
is it women or men wow i know
i know how these women are men that send
you the death threats usually that are
that that have the angry stuff both damn
do you get the only reason you're
catching these fish because you're
pretty
yeah oh yeah all the time from some
selfie men who fish their whole lives
and
suck at fishes call talent hannah i'd
but that's because he bites twice
because he eats a lot that's what he
does
yeah i go for seconds
there you go well hannah yeah obviously
we're turning into some of those
perverts so we're gonna
apparently i think phil sent a few of
those so i apologize
we're gonna shut it down now but uh let
us know when you get those shirts we
want to wear some of them
i sure will and i do appreciate it yeah
thank you so much for brightening up our
day
yeah you're the best good luck with the
fish thank y'all y'all come fishing with
me
we're down we're down
it's a bad trait when i get turned on
one eye gets a little lazy
[Laughter]
[Music]
it's the king of nice games